more than 120 retired generals and
admirals sign open letter questioning
biden's mental health and backing
election fraud claims i mentioned this
and the first thing that jack said what
did you say are we back to trusting uh
you know retired officials of all kinds
experts i mean didn't we just spend last
four years reading letters from all
kinds of lists of people saying a
hundred of these guys said that donald
trump is insane remember these guys 100
of these guys those guys and then under
those guys and now we got 120 of these m
f and guys
but i believe these guys that's right
because they think the way i think
that's right yes correct you know uh i
saw the 350 whatever former military uh
officers saying trump was unwell and i
was deeply offended and it was clearly
fake news clearly then i i opened up
this story from the daily mail and these
100 generals clearly are the ones who
are of sound mind they were the smart
ones obviously nothing but the best i
got to be honest though i i do think
these guys are right like biden is not
all there he's definitely not so i mean
you know obviously we have our bias i
suppose but uh here's the story from the
daily mail
they say
the letter echoes former president
trump's claims of widespread election
fraud which have been born uh which have
not been born out in the courts
and uh come on a day when liz cheney
ripped trump for his claim the election
was stolen now i'll mention this too
what may be the stupidest most boring
story i have ever seen in any news cycle
liz cheney getting stripped of some
republican committee woman position who
is she
jenny's daughter i'm joking
no no but what was her position what was
her position i have no idea and who
cares i have no character i'm like i'm
sitting here reading the news and it's
like two weeks ago there was reports out
of ohio nebraska uh uh and arkansas food
shortages a bunch of different
restaurants are like we can't get food
why you see these stories about how
people are walking off the job like we
don't want to work at wendy's or
whatever that's happening at processing
plants it's happening at factories it's
happening at steel mills happening
everywhere people get paid not to work
i'm seeing that story we'll get into
more of that later i'm seeing the story
i'm like wow this is scary and then i
look on twitter and it's like liz janey
liz cheney i'm like who cares about liz
cheney is there is there is there a 45
year old dad you know looking at his two
daughters in the corner thinking to
himself like oh man if liz cheney
doesn't get removed i don't know my
future's going to be like or my
daughter's no he's like do i have food
tomorrow is there gasoline the democrats
just shut down are demanding another
pipeline be shut down in michigan
because they're worried at a leak in the
in the lake which hasn't happened before
apparently and it's weird timing to shut
down a pipeline when we have this other
thing going on anyway i digress that'd
be three in one year for them yeah
exactly wow so let's see what these uh
these this year generally and that was
that was just the day after that that
was like basically the head i think of
all the department of energy maybe was
our department of transportation one of
them the lady was saying well pipelines
are definitely the best way to that's
right
yep
talk about weird it's it's i gotta say
it when i saw that story about democrats
shutting down the pipeline in north
michigan it goes into ontario i guess
for for uh processing refining but still
that helps supply the region and i'm
just like are they
trying to destroy everything are they
are they actually like mustache twirling
villains who want to burn the system
down because it's it's like what i don't
know what to say i've been having this
feeling lately where like i'm like am i
doing the the biden version of tds where
like everything that happens is
definitely his fault and definitely part
of a grand scheme and definitely
evidence that they're trying to kill us
all and destroy the country one step at
a time right in front of our faces yeah
no eds
yes they are no they're not no you're
not you're not you don't have bite into
arrangements i don't think i don't have
binders i don't think it's biden though
i think that there's he's just a pawn
that doesn't isn't cognizant enough to
be aware of what's going on around him
well so so let's let's take a look at
this letter real quick and then i i do
think that we will we'll lead off with
that because that's a really good point
and i think the answer is no we don't
have biden derangement syndrome i think
some people do absolutely i think
there's people who are building careers
off of like biden is always bad no when
when biden announced he was moving up
the vaccine schedule i gave him credit i
was like that's
fantastic absolutely uh donald trump was
the one who did all the work for this
donald trump deserves credit for
operation warp speed joe biden saying
we're going to increase production move
the schedule it's a good thing it's not
like he won a war or like ended a war or
got everybody rich or anything but you
know i try to give credit where credit
is due no he started wars and made us
all poor right exactly and that's bad
stuff yeah that was bad you know 2019
best numbers of our lives jim cramer
whether you trust the guy or not but
anyway here's the letter and i'll read
i'll read to some of it so you get the
general idea
well i'll actually i'll read the
highlights because reading the whole
letter they say
quote election integrity demands
ensuring there is one legal vote cast
and counted per election legal votes
identified by state legislatures
approved controls using government ids
verified signatures etc etc they write
they have a huge list like let me read
this one
the mental and physical condition of the
commander-in-chief cannot be ignored he
must be able to quickly make accurate
national security decisions involving
life and limb anywhere day or night
recent democrat leadership
inquiries about nuclear code procedures
sends a dangerous national security
signal to nuclear-armed adversaries
raising the question about who is in
charge we must always have an
unquestionable chain of command
100 we talked about this on this show
when the democrats were like maybe biden
shouldn't be the only one with nuclear
capabilities like with the codes and
it's like what are you telling the world
when you say that
trinidad shabbat a pressure what do you
think
kim jong-un is thinking when you watch
joe biden say that or when he sees joe
biden go i'm going to get in trouble if
i answer questions so i gotta leave
how would you feel if you walked into a
tent in the middle of a war you were at
war with your comrades and you walked
into a tent and joe biden was there the
general and you were like what do we do
and he's like oh he'd be removed
immediately immediately immediately he
has as far as i know zero combat ex zero
military he would have gotten fragged a
long time ago hold on trump trump
doesn't have any combat experience zero
however you walk in and donald trump is
going we are not going to allow them no
excuse me we are not letting him take
that front i want more soldiers there no
it's quiet excuse me and they're like
okay okay joe biden's going you know uh
the the one strategy
we gotta we ought to focus uh
anyway yeah that's when the guys take
them out that's when they say okay
grandpa come on you stumble and don't i
mean they walk you mean they walk him
out of the room yeah they remove him
from his position right jessie kelly had
a great tweet about this today he's also
going to be live on jack murphy live
tomorrow 12 15 jessie kelly
uh thank you the guests are getting
better i have some great guests coming
up as well um and he's pointed out he's
like look if you're a bad guy out there
in the world this is your moment to make
your move this is your moment to make
your move because there's nobody
on watch nobody seems to care and if
they do care they kind of want to help
you you know like it's you know it's a
moment of weakness you know what it
feels like it's like the the democrats
right now are the equivalent of a bunch
of like minors who put on trench coats
on top of each other's shoulders and
snuck into a frat party and so now they
know that the amount of time they have
in this party is limited so they're like
just grab as much as you can and they're
like drinking and then like you know the
the the the frat leader guy he's like
some some you know douche bro who's like
yo what are these kids doing here get
them out of here basically my analogy is
yeah they're in the system there's no
leadership it's wild out of control and
they're extracting and extracting and
extracting and just like
watching the whole thing fall down
because they want to get as much as they
can before they get the boot because
they know they're getting the boot and
then binds like
i don't know man give me six pounds hold
on biden is the grandpa they use to
sneak into the ball oh yeah alcohol
right these are my kids
they're all 50. they're like okay
grandpa and then you know did the
generals put their names behind this oh
yeah yeah that's legitimate any names
that we know
let me see look at some photos major
general joe arbuckle oh arbuckle that's
a name
wow do you want me to read all the names
yes i'm just kidding i guess a few maybe
uh i don't what does mg stand for major
general yeah i think so major general
joseph t anderson
what's r-a-d-m philip uh and selmo
joseph arbuckle john eric
johnson
yeah yeah there you go
john w bayless james best there's so
many titles in here like charles bishop
i'm not going to read it edward biggs
richard tex brown who they call him text
the third whoa he's a third or something
that's cool it doesn't sound like a very
diverse bunch joe owens jimmy pappas hey
jimmy pappas huh paul mock
leonard f the coat do we have any john
poindexter
i don't know um i don't i don't know i
see a john white that's the opposite oh
yeah i don't know
how many women
no no women how many people of color
with no women no people color i just
obviously i don't trust it a lot of
richards i don't know
john's
uh ken hager
hageman how many total 180 120. so what
are there
660 generals all across the u.s military
completely and we're looking at that
these are these are these are these are
retirees oh they're all retired okay but
still a third of
the the total number of general ship of
the united states more more uh yeah well
but they're retiring they're about they
are retired more people condemned trump
it was like 357 or whatever retired
officers who were like trump is bad that
was the easy that was the easy play so
let me let me tell you something
you do not have vitamin d arrangement
syndrome for criticizing body when he's
doing bad things i mean did you
criticize trump when trump did bad
things yes constantly yeah well would
trump fire tombok missiles into syria
uh fired darren
michael anton all kinds of bad things
didn't fire a bunch of people brought on
john bolton yeah no not anton now it's
it's it's it's very simple
uh
we act asking this question we're very
actively trying to make sure we're not
just playing that game you know yeah and
that's actually a weakness in terms of
the the cultural conflict the left
doesn't do that
there what happened remember remember
when joe biden was like bombing syria
and this woman she was the woman from
new york times was like waking up on
sunday and there's no tweets from trump
so relaxed wasn't that jennifer rubin i
think oh reuben okay and i'm like you
know we're just watching the news seeing
like you know kids blow up and stuff but
uh go to sleep go to sleep you've been
sleeping the whole time anyway so don't
bother waking up you'll only make a mess
of it again if you do well look rigorous
investigation is not the hallmark of the
left i recently uh tweeted out some
information from education on the left
where the slide said that if you look at
data and the only conclusion that you
come up with is that this if you don't
come up with the idea that the system is
broken that for whatever reason that
kids have different outcomes the data is
wrong the system's broken or you're a
bigot
that's it
sounds about right
i think that's okay that's how you use
data that's what research is all about
yeah so uh to be critical of joe biden
the way that we were of donald trump i
think is not something that we're going
to see a lot of on the left someone
tweeted
they were they were like it's been four
months
and already we're dealing with all of
these crises and then somewhat some
lefty responded with how is this in any
way the result of biden policies and i
was like imagine living in that world
where you don't know what biden's been
doing and for those that are listening
who are like i bet tim's not even give
an example
joe biden rescinded the executive orders
from donald trump and issued 50 or so
executive orders on his own some of
those executive orders were the remain
in mexico policies which resulted in a
poll factor and now we have more migrant
children in detention another thing that
happened was that joe biden reopened the
homestead facility and put more kids in
cages they don't seem to care about it
aoc who once at their concentration
camps is now saying their their migrant
what what did you call them facilities
with controversial records it's a big
step up from uh concentration camps two
star hotels that's right two stars joe
biden is also proposing that we increase
we we extend the unemployment benefits
of 300 a week for for another large
amount of time or undetermined amount of
time and the chamber of commerce
commerce said this is resulting in
people walking off the job and we need
to stop it 11 republican governors have
now said they're not going to accept
this money because it's destroying the
economy joe biden is responsible for
these things it is joe biden's policies
he restored funding to uh
political factions in gaza and now all
of a sudden convict is breaking out i am
not going to sit here and say look at
joe biden he's making moves on the
economy with mass spending the democrats
and republicans are responsible for that
last year joe biden is now exacerbating
it things are getting worse joe biden is
telling people when it comes to
immigration the the words of the
president matter but it's also his
policies
these things are having an impact joe
biden goes in and starts talking about
israel and having to be responsible and
having you know having accountability
and then all of a sudden now this whole
thing is is bubbling up i understand i
can't blame the president for israel and
palestine that's a huge conflict that
goes back a decent amount of time but
you look in manhattan when people are
beating each other in the streets you
look at the actions of the us attorneys
who have been cutting loose the far left
extremists dropping felony charges in
the pacific northwest and the violence
is getting worse even finally the local
news is talking about it so there are
just a few examples of what joe biden
has done which is causing very serious
consequences and i'll tell you this tell
me when he says
we are going to continue the
unemployment benefits 16 an hour and
then you see all of this crazy stuff
happening with the exodus from the
workforce and the left these these young
20-something dsa people democratic
socialists don't understand math they're
like yay give us benefits we shouldn't
have to work at all it's like okay well
if you don't make stuff you don't get
stuff so if no one's making stuff then
you got no stuff to make or to buy to do
anything with
that's just some of it that's just thank
you for those examples tim i appreciate
that it's fire you always have citations
well it's because i'm not just making
things up like i don't like joe biden
according to ballot pedia he signed 43
executive orders 16 presidential
memorandum 69 proclamations and 13
notices on day one he made since he's
been in office dramatic
he took dramatic actions unprecedented
levels of executive orders and
memorandums and now all of these things
happen around the same time surely it
was a coincidence trump was just you
know putting duct tape over the holes
and then as soon as he left the duct
tape popped off that's what happened
right it's all trump's fault no it's a
busted machine or joe biden got in and
said change change change change change
change change and pop
the board it's always an interesting
thing to see like when trump came into
office the economy was doing okay and
they're like can't be trump's fault
can't be can't be trump trump didn't do
it how long how long into the presidency
has become theirs but in this economy
does take some time the inflation was
probably baked in starting last year and
it's getting worse now with these new
packages
but the decisions that he made around
the executive orders and foreign policy
changes and and immigration changes and
things like that those are huge
impactful right now policy changes
stephen miller for all things you want
to criticize that guy for he crafted an
immigration policy that slowed the flow
of refugees or of of illegal immigrants
it slowed uh the massing of immigrants
at the border it slowed the number of
kids in the cages and the detention
centers in the two-star hotels depending
on his talking
it slowed all that stuff they rescind
all of it and now it just blows up
joe biden was uh under his policies
allowing illegal immigrants to come in
who were coveted positive and then they
were immediately released into texas at
a time when you could not travel you
could not go to restaurants that was the
biggest punch in the gut the spit in the
face to the american people we gotta we
gotta we gotta ban travel to india so
saith joe biden media says that's a okay
that's not racist well joe biden said it
was xenophobic after trump banned travel
to china we get it joe biden and the
media are hypocrites they want political
power now that they got into the party
they are extracting from the system and
watching it burn before us did kamala
harris go down to the border when she
was tasked with dealing with the crisis
no she laughed at the reporter who asked
her she openly
i'm not going down there
oh as if to say you are a stupid piece
of garbage for thinking i would ever do
anything to serve the american people i
don't stay at two star hotels get the
hell out of here you're coming harris
heaven forbid she has to actually go and
look at those those poors
i think i have i have kamala harris
arrangement syndrome kamala harris
responded to that reporter
the only poor people i'm interested in
seeing are the people who attend to my
pores at the spa it's a futurama joke i
like how you've been using the word
pores i mean i don't really like it but
i feel like 21st century that might
become derogatory yeah that's that's the
point i'm mocking those people for call
for for you know there's no room for
sarcasm here i know right of course
terrifying because it really is a class
issue and in the future they may really
look at the pores like it's a race of
people i i can't when watching kamala
harris laugh in the face of that
reporter for asking if she would if she
would go to the border kamala harris
protested the homestead facility aoc
protested this
the biden administration reopened the
facility where the children were being
detained now i understand that i did not
go after biden for that what i'm
criticizing is the double standard
you need to have kids somewhere when
trump was doing i was like what are we
gonna do just leave the kids in the
desert you gotta put them somewhere and
we gotta we can do better i suppose but
how are you gonna protest that
then be part of the administration that
reopens it and when someone says will
you go to the border you laugh in their
face now not to defend that psycho but
it's it's clear
that her laughter is a sign of her own
cognitive dissonance right it's clearly
when she's challenged she's
uncomfortable she knows she's wrong or
she doesn't know the answer or whatever
it is she just cackles because she knows
she's caught of course i don't i don't
the question was will you go down to the
border she wasn't caught on anything she
just started laughing she hasn't been
she's not prioritizing it one of the
things this was this was right when
biden was like i'm tasking commodore
dealing with this she was boarding a
plane they were like will you be heading
out to the border and she laughed and
said not today
it's like she's the wicked witch of the
west
you think i would actually care for
these children give me your political
power that's what she does she just
needs a tiny bit of makeup can we get a
meme of like her we need her to be like
to merge her face with the emperor
you know
yeah base window scene
oh my gosh i'm sure it's out there they
like slowly turns into combo and then
back into
like a deep fake that's what she wants
and joe biden is just sitting there like
you know uh somebody tweeted my favorite
quote from joe biden my favorite
presidential quote from joe biden and
he's like i can't i don't remember the
exact quote but he says something like
you know the one way to get ahead and
with the dream and to fight with to go
anyway
that was really i was about as
exhilarating then as it was now
anyway like what were you going to say
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you